[Music]
yours this is us kids and grandkids are
here no I like just looking at the
island so thrilled we're just like the
whole cast is one big giant family so
it's always nice to get the opportunity
to hang yes the kids of it this is us
stepped out to support co-star Mandy
Moore at the premiere of shingles a
series they're rocking a-team Rapunzel
shirt my mother had it sent remains of
course we have to get them to spill some
unset secret what is Mandy like as a
co-star the TV mom I can't even describe
how Sweet Pea and he like helps us with
that line there he rehearses with us and
she's a really good mom to have on set
it's very cool to all the cab is very
nice and then if we mess up we can be
helpless which of your co-stars is the
most fun on set er the most fun to act
twist I don't know she really is so
funny and I love how you keep on
encouraging me because if I mess up
feels like messing up the kind of life
you've got this feeling is really
awesome and saving cash whenever we
won't have to wait on set they always
have just free stuff and it's really
funny because language and then
sometimes we say madam I really like
have a connection with Marlo that makes
us like like have a bond like father and
real son to me you are every part my son
you guys get to watch the full episodes
or do you only see your scene I get to
watch the full episode and I love it
like whenever and I can't panic close my
eyes because I don't like to see when
their campaign because I know them so
it's kind of weird and I know that
they're not married in real life when I
would cover my eyes or something is like
and if ever a like that when we have to
explain welcoming my eyes I want to know
what's happening so I want the Embassy
is there anything that you've seen on
set or had to talk about it you're like
what is this
yeah a lot some of our outfit yeah
sometimes they're like really crazy like
the TV and then they still little and it
has it's like a box and then our door
right now like flat screen yeah they're
just too into foods now what can we
expect
well they don't really tell me anything
the excess power is going to be fine but
sad and it's not self raises Williams
lies under rolling
I don't you know you can expect a lot of
more drama and a lot more impact and
action coming Lou action that's quite
the promise
pretty much
you